o que eu sei que eu chamo me acontece
agora a grande questão dispõe é o que é
que eu sou e eu pensei muitas vezes
nisso e eu gosto desta proximidade vôo
vou passear entre vocês e descobri que
era produto das minhas vivências isso
pergunta que eu faço é vocês sabem quem
são
acho que se deve questionar sobre isso
agora uma coisa que os quer surpreender
é que 1
eu tenho certeza que vocês lançavam e
isto kawasaki na ligação do meu colega é
que eu sou astronauta sem fax um
astronauta porque na quarta 4 surgiu
aquela famosa pergunta na ação o que
quer ser quando fosse grave e eu pensei
disse não uniu a moção não vai ter são
as pegadas dell
as meninas também vão instalar e eu
pensei foi que lhes eu vou ser um
astronauta então criei uma lista de
coisas a fazer para ser um astronauta
senador era uma delas é obrigatório que
resolvi fazer para ser senador
criaram o primeiro filme factos e olhe o
méxico é a minha despensa com uma
lanterna uma caixa de sapato e um
simples plástico com uma caneta
fiz várias projeções não tem muito
público
mas descobri uma coisa incrível e eu
conseguia concretizar os meus sonhos
depois como todos sabem a ser astronauta
é preciso ter um cão quem é que iria
guardar a minha estação espacial na qual
laranjeiras junto ao poço com deu a
construir o que bairro rex um raro o seu
compromisso em ajudar uma passear
semaninha nave espacial uma bicicleta
com um evento incrível não ajudavam na
quinta nave espacial às secretas tem uma
coisa fantástica só precisam nós e da
nossa atitude
são 50 e naves espaciais depois
quis mais coisas hoje pretendo uma coisa
muito interessante é ter outra nave
espacial compostos e vive em toda a
gente gosta desse tipo de naves
espaciais em um escala não é mais
correto é um para 18
mas eu acho que era a altura e se isto
te léxico revai entrevistados foi a
escalou para 1
[Música]
depois eb1 exposto muito muito muito
interessante que era obrigatório eu
tenho uma mulher fantástica e filipeta
quase factoring escalou para 1 são reais
e tem sido extremamente desafiantes
porque se calhar por eles eu também
estou aqui hoje e portanto são exigentes
e nós quando somos exigentes programamos
tempo
tanto eu fui cumprindo a minha lista da
astronauta foi conseguindo as minhas
coisas fantásticas
pois é mas com uma altura que eu não
sentia um astronauta
eu costumava ter a isso não tava isso na
cabeça do engenheiro era complicado é o
hospital está tudo correto olhe pra
minha vida não está correta daqui como
fazer hang seng me fez literalmente isto
virei as costas à vida disse não isso
não pode acontecer
eu não eu não acredito que isto esteja a
acontecer tudo aquilo que o clube fiquei
mesmo assim ninguém gosta
vocês vão gostar que não é vida também
não gostou e tem que escolher um caminho
vocês certeza que estavam os astronautas
têm uma coisa fantástica constroem
cliente deixa de ser astronauta deixe de
ver o meu caminho
então tem que construir um caminho anda
como quando que queria fazer os livros
ea algae uma coisa básica disse eu vou
voltar à universidade
não sei muito bem por aqui mas tenho um
objetivo eu vou encontrar no caminho e
assim foi o entendimento que fiz em
termos da unicer awa o momento incrível
foi primeiro ao rio senti uma coisa que
eu acho que vocês também consegue sentir
quando tudo parece para nós
eudes pai primeira aula
tá que conta o que fazer o sangue eu tô
construir um look mim agora é minha
grande decisão vai ser em fio é como
ficar na primeira fila na isso não é
minha praia não vou ficar na primeira
série no maiô
neste de lá no fundo do ônibus que temos
é um ano da minha vida
então surgiu uma coisa que os hoje todos
os dias como já faz parte nada é porque
não não porque não faz primeira fila e
fui fui para a primeira seu então
sistematizar uma coisa que eu gostaria
verão em uma forma fantástica um pouco
não é um desafio não é uma coisa na arca
é um desafio do fato que nós nos
sentimos esse ponto não temos que
discutir ficar agora onde é que nos
levam porque não dava por ray
continuamos na mesma
mais valia ter o papel do fundo ou então
pode usar uma coisa fantástica eu chamo
de atitude
atitude é a ferramenta do fazer
acontecer
imagine uma forma científica muitos anos
um pouco não é mais uma atitude então
esposa fundar o meu mundo
foi isso que aconteceu eu hoje sul
o tal produto das minhas vivências que
conseguir através desta simples situação
um portugal mais marcante tudo uma
formulação do nosso mundo
agora já não estava de costas sentiu
outra vez um astronauta
então o que é que o astronauta vai fazer
com vida deu então fui criando algumas
dinâmicas que hoje gostaria de partilhar
convosco
acho que um é temos que nesta atitude e
fazer acontecer
alguns postos o meu primeiro foi
combater a obesidade ambiental
vocês não imaginam
antes se vê pela primeira fila os quilos
que eu tinha mais
agora como é que se combata o
fundamental andando de bicicleta
então criei um projeto de motocicleta
movida a energia solar que propõe tem
uma eletrônica fantástico é que é o
nosso cérebro
nós temos algo mas nós é que mandamos já
tava tudo agora em tudo aquilo que eu
faço na minha vida tá em terroso
é isso que o faz sentir astronauta então
como é que foi morros foi ganhar ao
posso certinho pro bicicleta luta dos
marrons semáforo vermelho um poste uma
bicicleta e ainda por cima direitinha o
semáforo muda eu faço pedal e acelera
fundo vocês vão ver a cara do contorno
posse é fantástico tanto aqui terroso
nas coisas
inovar inovar precisas e nunca por sim o
que querem inovação nunca ouvia toda a
gente a falar em inovação você não vai
reservar um dia estava com minha mãe e
vi uma fotografia minha do team ninja
com bigode esperar e não era gestor do
mundo mudou o túmulo gasto então fez um
clipe
se o mundo muda se o uso e o que eu faço
não é isso um indício
então para sair valorizar a inovação
hoje eu tenho um truque é facílimo
facílimo de inovar inovar para mim é
simplesmente isto
é ver as coisas de forma diferente e
supostamente estar ali morador uma
grande palestra eo towel nos em sou eu e
eu quero ver as coisas forma de
enfrentar este novo processo de inovação
enquanto em algumas reuniões em que não
consigo ficar lá
subo e pão nem pé em cima da secretária
o colar foi bem acima da secretaria essa
noção de perspectiva de conflito
interior
levamos uma clivagem pois passaria a
existir uma empresa fantástica
contraprovas fantásticos
ok variam caso a cotação das ações
dessas empresas chamas e minha família
s/a
o capitão invisto tenho o tempo nestes
cuidados no conhecimento e os pagãos em
beijing o grid em flat em partilha é
fantástico polga pena investir nessa
dessas empresas e com isto tudo foi um
fumante da minha vida como alguém disser
eu já não vou alongar mais o que eu
queria dizer
hoje eu consigo estar aqui consigo
expressar aqui 15 que a comunicação é
importante comunicar em política
comprometimento compromisso e hoje quero
comprometer convosco que acredito
naquilo que estou a dizer
eu acredito que um porco não é uma
atitude nós conseguimos formular o nosso
mundo
eu mudei o meu quanto vocês querem mudar
voz o fato
eu sou astronauta nunca pisar a lua mas
vive o sonho de emoções de conseguir
algo que acredito
obrigado
[Aplausos]